oh they're asking me these questions in
GQ and this one's tailored sweatpants
they're okay with me
legalized marijuana is always a very
difficult question for medicinal
purposes for medical purposes
absolutely it's fine we have to help
people but at the same time people have
to come into our country legally we need
to have a border we need to have
security in our country Chuck Norris is
a terrific guy talented guy I really
like them I don't know if he likes me
but I like him again gqueues asking me
about man buns never been my thing I
must admit bringing back the gold
standard would be very hard to do but
boy would it be wonderful we'd have a
standard on which to base our money
great personality great demeanor great
persona we like the Pope they want to
know whether or not we should deport
Justin Bieber I say absolutely not
well electric car seemed to be the thing
of the future the funny thing is if
you've ever played golf the electric
golf carts are much better than the
gasoline version so I guess electric is
going to be right down the road Hillary
Clinton has a lot of problems with the
emails it'll be very very interesting to
see whether or not she runs but I think
she probably will end up running and I
think I'll be here